- Afternoon, I'm Gav.
- Good day to you, I'm Dan.
- Very formal.
We're the Slow Mo Guys.
Now, in the past we've done giant balloons
full of water popping.
- [Dan] Yep.
- [Gav] Never seen how big they got
with just air in them, though.
- I wonder how big it gets, yeah.
- Well, supposedly six feet.
So I'm thinking we could
sit you on top of one.
- Yep.
- And pop it.
See if you'd be hovering in the air,
and when that inevitably fails,
we'll stick you inside it.
- In just a balloon full of air.
- Yeah, I mean that's
what they're meant for
they're climb-in balloons.
I wonder if you could
actually be able to stand
fully upright inside there?
- That would be awesome.
- Like strike a pose.
You think you could do that?
- Just in a balloon.
- Yeah and just like .
- I tried blowing it up with my mouth,
it wasn't happening, so,
got a leaf blower.
- Now funnily enough
this is not a leaf blower
that I actually owned already,
we bought it specifically
for this purpose.
I'm glad we went for blue on blue,
very easy to see what's happening.
All right, now lie on it.
- Lie on it now?
- [Gav] Yeah.
Put your hands behind your back.
- It's too big!
Too big.
I'm stood up.
I'm stood up on it.
I can't get on it.
- [Gav] Jump.
So, because we want you
actually sat on the balloon
we're now doing some
anchorage for a handles
for you to hold onto.
- Yeah, I'm gonna tie these
two strings to the trees
and hopefully, just sort of balance
my way on top of the
balloon, leaning back.
- [Gav] Do you have
good core strength Gee?
I could be all about the stomach
I think.
- Second to none.
- [Gav] Second to none?
Whoa!
hell.
- [Gav] All right, so that
failed it got too big,
so I guess climb inside and we'll see
if we can pop it with you inside.
- How is it not letting the air out?
- It is.
- [Gav] Is it?
- Yep.
- [Gav] Why don't you
just climb in head first?
- No, idiot.
Why don't I just climb in head first!
What's your problem?
Moron.
- [Gav] That looks stupid though.
Don't most people put it over their heads?
- No.
- Yeah.
- They have their heads out of it,
that's the one thing they
have out of it you moron.
I'm blowing away here.
Ow, ah,
Ow my leg hair, Free.
Ah it's so painful.
- [Gav] Oh my God!
- I need to be moistened.
- [Gav] You don't,
just get in it.
- Moisten me.
- [Gav] I'm not gonna moisten you.
Right, you want me to help
you pull it over your knees?
- So tight.
No, I can't even get it off
with out it hurting me either.
- [Gav] All right, we'll
fire up the leaf blower again
to get more air.
- That's not gonna help.
- [Gav] It will.
- It's not.
- [Gav] You might as well get out
and try getting on it again.
- It's so, God damn.
- [Gav] Thoughts?
It looks like a ...
- [Dan] I'll do it, Oh God!
- [Gav] You should be like, over there
and then the shoulders.
- [Dan] Round my shorts, round the shorts.
- [Gav] Round the shorts?
- [Dan] Round the shorts.
Watch out for the buttons Free.
- [Dan] Free, I'm getting naked in here,
it's pulling my shorts down.
- [Gav] That does not look appealing.
- Whoa!
Whoa!
My pose went straight out the window.
I was like this, then just went, whoa!
- That pose was phenomenal.
- Thank you, cheers.
- It actually worked exactly
how I imagined it would.
- I had so much time in there,
I was literally like
"What pose shall I do?"
And I was stood in the balloon like
"Hmm, I don't know what's best?"
Yeah.
- It would be a great unveiling.
- Yeah.
- If I ever had to replace you,
I'd unveil the new one like that.
- New slimmer guy.
- Hopefully you enjoyed that video.
Feel free to follow us on the Twits,
but a shirt, buy a poster.
- Subscribe.
- Subscribe, the most
important one of all.
- Watch all of our other videos,
we've got over a hundred.
- These days.
- Click, click, click, click, click.
Hours.
- See you next time.